[Musique]
et re bonsoir donc jacques merci d'être
avec vous ce soir on va passer au crible
ces bons chiffres du chômage
clairement est ce que ces chiffres ils
sont justifiés cet optimisme actuelle du
gouvernement en matière d'économie et il
faut alors il est très clair que ou
troisième trimestre la situation a été
bien meilleurs que prévu on le voit sur
la baisse du nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi a exactement les chômeurs on le
voit aussi sur le redémarrage de
l'économie bon ça c'est une chose qui
est avérée après la question que sa peau
c'est un est-ce que ça va au delà de la
fameuse catégorie a et ça c'est une
vraie question parce que si la situation
était aussi bonne qu'on le prétendait et
bien il y aurait une forme de diffusion
deuxièmement et bien cette espèce de
relance que l'on a alors même si on
reste en dessous du chiffre de la baisse
de l'année dernière et bien cette
relance est les cas c'est normal et est
ce qu'elle est suffisante pour nous
permettre de surmonter le choc de
l'année dernière ça c'est encore une
autre question et enfin il ya toujours
cette question qui se pose est ce que ça
peut durer et là malheureusement on voit
qu'il ya des nuages noirs qui
s'accumulent sur l'horizon économique
alors qu'en est il de cette baisse du
chômage alors sur la baisse du chômage
il faut dire elle ne concerne
pratiquement que ce qu'on appelle la
catégorie a dans les données de la dares
ou de pôle emploi alors la catégorie à
il s'agit des gens qui sont sans emploi
qui sont à la recherche active d'un
emploi
mais il faut faire attention ce ne sont
pas eux qui constituent à eux seuls
l'ensemble des chômeurs parce qu'on a
d'autres catégories par exemple vous
avez la catégorie b sont grosso modo des
gens qui travaillent moins de 10 euros
20 heures par mois on voit très bien
qu'ils ne peuvent pas vivre avec ça donc
ils sont considérés en fait comme
chômeur ou comme demandeur d'emploi il
ya aussi d'ailleurs des d'autres
personnes qui sont tout simplement
exemptés de l'obligation de recherche
d'emploi pourquoi il s'agit par exemple
des femmes enceintes des personnes qui
sont temporairement mal bon ce que l'on
voit c'est que ces deux autres
catégories b et d dans le langage
technique de la dares et de pôle emploi
et bien non seulement elles ne
connaissent pas de baisse mais en fait
elle monte un petit peu ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point c'est quand
on regarde ce bloc de chemin à b et d et
puisqu'on peut considérer pour parler un
petit peu rapidement comme des quasi
chômeurs c'est à dire les catégories c
et e ce sont soit des gens qui sont en
stage de manière très temporaire soit
les gens qui ne sont pas en plein emploi
mais qui sont quand même avec un emploi
partiel a un petit peu plus que les 20
heures par mois précédent bref sur les
catégories c et e puis on voit que ça
reste absolument stable donc en réalité
cette baisse du chômage n'a correspondu
au troisième trimestre qu'à la catégorie
a est alors la question évidemment à
quoi sont dues ces différences alors on
peut le contrôler assez simplement
intuitivement
après le troisième confinement le
confinement du mois d'avril dernier bon
les entreprises ont rouvert elles ont
repris et elles se sont heurtées à un
mur de l'emploi c'est qu'elle avait
besoin de trouver des travailleurs quels
sont les premiers chômeurs qui peuvent
être employés à ça effectivement les
gens dans la catégorie ya donc mais tout
à fait normal que ce soit eux qui soit
allée les premiers sur le marché de
l'emploi qu'ils soient rentrés sur le
marché de l'emploi est d'ailleurs de
manière assez importante un
5,8 pour cent au troisième trimestre et
grosso modo 10 % sur un an après si le
phénomène devait durer et bien cela se
verrait par le fait qu'il perd collerait
dans les autres catégories or ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est que ça ne
perturbe pas ça ne console ça ne
concerne que la catégorie ya donc c'est
pour cela qu'il ya un vrai problème
alors jacques pourquoi le gouvernement
parle d'une croissance inédite en france
qui croire écoutez si on pense si on
regarde les chiffres il n'a pas tort on
est entre 6 2 et 6 3 % de croissance
sur deux on sera quand on aura les
chiffres du quatrième trimestre bon
c'est un très beau résultat et c'est
effectivement l'un des meilleurs
résultats pratiquement depuis l'après
guerre maintenant quand on regarde la
chute que l'on a connu en 2020 on est
loin du compte on a eu un pib qui a
baissé de 8% il va augmenter d'à peu
près 6 % l'année suivante oui mais ça ne
compense pas les 8% perdu et d'ailleurs
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
quand on regarde les données qu a
collationné le fonds monétaire
international sur la base des instituts
des gouvernements etc on voit que la
france a été l'un des pays qui a connu
le choc le plus important d'autres pays
comme par exemple l'allemagne la suède
où les états unis n'ont pas connu un
choc de même ampleur est par ailleurs le
re démarrage se fait vous êtes au moins
vite que dans d'autres pays ainsi nous
ne retrouverons notre niveau de pib de
2019 que dans le cours de l'année 2022
probablement entre mars et août 2022 bon
mais pas avant donc il ya un vrai
problème de ce point de vue là il faut
comprendre que évidemment quand on a une
chute très fort il est assez normal
qu'on ait une reprise forte l'année
d'après alors même réflexion qu'avant
quand on parlait du taux de pauvreté un
le gouvernement prétend que là encore
ces résultats sont le produit du quoi
qu'il en coûte
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est là où
je dirais le discours du gouvernement
est peut-être le plus critiquable parce
que formellement bien sûr quand on
gratte un petit peu les chiffres c'est
différent mais formellement il n'a pas
tort sur les autres questions après sur
le quoi qu'il en coûte ce que l'on voit
c'est que oui bien sûr la france a plus
aider ces entreprises et sa population
que la moyenne de l'union européenne
mais moins que ses principaux
partenaires par exemple nous avons fait
entre les engagements budgétaires et les
garanties de prêts des garanties de
crédit nous avons fait environ 25% du
pib en allemagne est à 43 % 43 %
l'italie est à peu près au même niveau
la grande bretagne
aussi est un niveau très élevé alors ça
prouve que d'abord on en a fait
peut-être moins que nos voisins et
lorsqu'il le plus intéressant c'est que
l'italie était dans une situation
financière est en fait plus dégradée que
la france est pourtant nous fait plus
donc on voit bien que ce n'est pas
simplement le fait qu'on était dans une
situation dégradée qui nous a retenus
donc il ya un vrai problème politique là
et il faut comprendre que quand le
gouvernement dit oui nous avons fait le
poids qu'il en coûte nous sommes un
exemple pour l'ensemble de l'union
européenne et ça veut dire en gros
jacques que ses os ses progrès ne sont
pas liés aux politiques des états c'est
ça alors je ne dis pas ça je dis
simplement qu'il ya des choix différents
qui ont été faits et que le choix qui a
été fait par le gouvernement français a
été un choix en fait de moindres
soutient que ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement allemand ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement italien ou que ce qu'a fait
le gouvernement britannique donc ça veut
dire que le gouvernement on a fait un
petit peu trop et trop tôt pour crier
victoire alors il en a fait passer et
ils crient pourtant victoire est là on
voit qu'il ya un vrai problème alors je
reprends un petit peu c'est que oui il
n'a pas tort de dire qu'effectivement le
troisième trimestre de 2021 a été bon on
le constate bien mais il faut comprendre
une chose hein sur la question du
chômage il n'y a pas de diffusion de ce
retour à l'emploi or la catégorie à donc
ça pose un véritable problème ensuite on
a la question savoir qu'est ce que c'est
que ces augmentations d'emploi et en
fait on voit que la france est restée
dans son modèle traditionnel autrement
dit nous sommes dans une économie de
services les emplois qui ont été recréés
sont essentiellement des emplois de
service des dalles à personne que ce
soit aux plus jeunes aux seniors et
c'est avec une baisse de la productivité
qui explique aussi cette forme de
reprise de l'emploi et qui va nous
mettre en difficulté
dans les années qui viennent par rapport
à nos voisins donc ça c'est un problème
important l'autre problème qui est très
important c'est de comprendre que la
situation économique globale est en
train en fait de se détériorer
on voit qu'il ya déjà des formes de
ralentissement en allemagne même en
italie ça commence à se voir et puis la
troisième question qu'est ce qui va se
passer du côté de l'abbé s'est
dernièrement madame christine lagarde a
été très attaqué par la presse allemande
d'ailleurs de manière pas très élégante
il faut il faut le dire qu'ils accusent
de ne pas mener la politique restrictive
que l'allemagne pense être nécessaire
alors effectivement si la bce change de
politique si par exemple en 2022 elle
commence à réduire fortement ses achats
de titres et elle commence à augmenter
ses taux et bien nous serons pas du tout
dans une situation où la croissance de
la fin de 2021 pourra se poursuivre et
on pourrait même connaître une nouvelle
cure d'austérité et ça sera peut-être
l'objet de notre édito de la semaine
prochaine pas de votre édito en tout cas
merci jacques sapir merci à vous donc la
semaine prochaine